>>Jon: What if I told you,
you could stop taking
papers home to grade?
Have I got your attention yet?
Well, you can in a
flipped class environment.
It frees up valuable class
time for interactions
and formative assessments
with your students.
>>Aaron: In a flip classroom,
you get a lot of time back.
That time that's now freed up,
since you're not delivering
direct instruction, you're doing
that outside of the
classroom through video,
you can use that for
formative assessment.
You can talk to every kid
in every class, every day,
in order to get them
moving along as well
as getting valuable
information for yourself
about who has mastered
what skills and concepts.
This gives you the power
to differentiate for each
of those individual students,
based on the feedback
that you're getting
from each of them.
So when a teacher is
checking in with each student
like that every day, they've
got a lot more information
to go from.
No longer does the
teacher need to wait
until that summative assessment,
that final exam or that end
of unit exam to know
where the students are at.
They have all sorts of
information and data in front
of them to know where each
kid is in their understanding
and their mastery
of these objectives.
>>Jon: Since you're going
to spend more time talking
to every kid in every
class, every day,
you're able to customize
the learning
and particularly the
assessments for each kid.
The kids are still going to
be learning the same content,
but they're going to
be learning in a way
that makes the most sense for
them, and also being assessed
in a way that is individualized
and differentiated for each kid.